next question accepting that the plural
of anecdote isn't data
what role can or may anecdotes play if
any in analysis
particularly repeated and or highly
translatable anecdotes or analyzing
qualitative rather than quantitative
circumstances
i wanted to pull something up actually
if you want to riff from it i want to
pull something up sure
um the the
sense of the danger of anecdotes is
way overdrawn and in some sense it is
designed
by the same people who are constantly
wielding
you know the data is king what do the
data say
um data-driven research these sorts of
things which sound right
you know it sounds sophisticated to be
skeptical
of anecdotes and it is it sounds very
sophisticated to say that the multiple
of anecdote is not data on the other
hand
first of all in a complex system when
you do observation
you are observing anecdotes that's how
you get to a hypothesis that's worthy of
test
and so
let's just say if anecdote exists in the
observational phase of scientific
research it's perfectly legitimate and
it just simply travels by a different
name
so in any case there are certain things
that are deployed to keep
a powerful group powerful and this is
one of them
so i would say correlation implies
causation when it's preceded by a
properly predictive hypothesis
despite what you've been told and uh
anecdote is a very important source of
information about a system it is not in
and of itself
a test of a hypothesis yep
though it can be used as a spot check
right you can have a hypothesis for some
reason
and then you can check it against the
anecdotes in your head and say
actually i don't believe that hypothesis
because i know six instances in which
they would have gone a different way
each of which were anecdotes
you can falsify with anecdote um so yeah
what i wanted to say i can't find the
actual uh paper but there's a
a reading that i used to give um from
barbara smutz
who's uh who was on my doctoral
committee and one of the important
researchers in baboon behavior and
specifically
um who focused on female baboon behavior
and in her book sex and friendship and
baboons
she wrote a bit about basically
the the kinds of data that you take in
the field and so i just went looking
into my methodology
behavioral methodology lectures that i
would give to students before i sent
them out to try to
start to become animal behaviorists and
i don't find it there but
um there she has a sort of a a taxonomy
of of course the kind of thing that you
can see over and over again between
individuals
and also keep track of the context in
which you saw them are the things that
we look for when we are going to
apply statistical analysis to the data
but there are two other categories
of things and i don't i just don't have
it in my head and i can't pull it up
here
um some of which happen occasionally
but under such dissimilar circumstances
that you couldn't that even though you
might have 10 instances you still can't
apply statistics to them because you
know that they're the same but they're
not the same enough
and then some of which you may actually
just see once or twice and so there is
no expectation
that you would actually um be able to
apply statistics and therefore you know
you can
and if you can't apply statistics we
basically don't call it
data except that and you know if it's
only one offer too often we tend to call
it anecdote
but over in um trying to understand
behavior land over in animal behavior
land
the rarest things are often the most
explanatory and certainly the most
exciting
so you know we know that chimps
sometimes wage war on one another
because jane goodall saw it happen once
over an extended period of days but it's
one i think it was a
i think it was a fissioning group um
that then drew a line
in the sand effectively and fighted with
one another fighted fight it
and then and then fought with one
another um and
similarly you will find um you know just
other kinds of territorial takeovers or
sexual takeovers or
um either between groups or the
replacement of an alpha
or um or defense um
by females by usurping male against
infanticide you know these sorts of
things happen rarely enough that you
may not have enough for data but once
you see it if you're out there trying to
understand
animals um you then have a very
different model of what it is that's
happening and what's driving them it's
the rare event that often is explanatory
and no we can't plug it into stats but
um it will be the thing that informs
our understanding maybe more than and
today
they've foraged again of course they did
right once upon a time
back before we became so stupid we used
to know this right
you still talking about us no we we are
trying to opt out of stupid it's
sometimes a full-time job but
um but you know it used to be that
natural history
was understood to be a scientifically
valid pursuit and in fact a very
important one
and the fact is the you know the uh
data-driven science people have among
other things they've driven out theory
and they've driven out
natural history so used to be you saw
something
remarkable like i once saw what i
believed to be a woodpecker riding on
the back of a crow
what it was amazing where uh
in a deep lake in uh in sun lakes in
eastern washington
um but in any case
i also saw a moose there right and moose
in in the desert right so here's the
thing there used to be a thing called a
natural history note
where you saw something it was
unmistakable what you saw and you
documented as much about
what it was that you saw and then you
just simply reported it so that
everybody would have the benefit of
effectively having seen the same thing
well actually i published one of these i
published one of these
um with regard to let's see i could have
done two which one did i publish
ah um with regard to my frogs in
madagascar at one point i'm sitting
there watching this marked population
of i've tattooed them so i know who all
the individuals are
and i've got a couple of fights going on
and with the very active fascinating
little poisonous frogs um and up from
the leaf later comes a boa
and uh grabs one of the female frogs i
knew i knew the frog so i know this is a
female
and uh all all the talking in the
landscape stops all the males stopped
talking and they all kind of everyone
kind of slinks off
and this boa kind of chews on the frog
for
10-15 minutes spits it out
this frog then goes on to become a
mother because i'm tracking her she's
tattooed i know i
see her engage in courtship and lay an
egg and
feeds her tadpoles and she she she ends
up fine
and this boa is no longer around after
that day
learn its lesson but that's one time
yeah that's one time i've got one
anecdotes fascinating but it is actually
a natural history note and i don't know
herpetological journal of herpetology
something yeah
so these things do still exist but
they're rarer and they're rarer and
they're not looked at
with the same kind of reverence that um
a database paper is but from the point
of view
of actually understanding nature man
give me a natural historian who knows
what they're doing
any day right these these people have
understood something deep and
um oh it's dan janssen the famous
tropical biologist
who once said um a biologist dies with
90
of what he knows right takes it to the
grave um
and this is unfortunate because in some
sense what a biologist accumulates over
or a naturalist accumulates over a
lifetime of watching creatures is really
very valuable stuff and it's just
impossible to record all of the things
that you've come to understand by all of
the anecdotes you've encountered
absolutely i mean it's actually part of
probably a small part but part of why
you and i find this
situation that's going on outside right
now so troubling
that um we both uh
create sense of our world by going out
into it and reflecting on the changing
of the seasons
and the plants and the birds and and you
know everything that's happening just in
our immediate vicinity
and being really unable to spend more
than a few minutes outside even while
masked and we don't have any n95 masks
but even while masked without feeling
you know
quite at risk at the moment uh puts us
such a remove from
an ability to interact with anything
that isn't
us or what we've created right here is
uh incredibly restricting
yeah it is it's turned us it's turned
our world into an
all social one which is something we
seek to avoid most of the time not that
we avoid all social stuff but we avoid
because we don't like each other very
much
now we avoid the complete socialness of
the world in any way it's been enforced
by smoke
[Music]
you